[Applause]
welcome to mario kart
[Music]
what does this mean 50cc
drew i thought i would tell you i've
started acquiring
signed novels
oh so this is my new collection thing
all right what have you got uh i got ecb
in my steinbeck wow i got uh t i got to
kill a mockingbird i got um
darkness at noon
wow that's great let's talk about
darkness darkness is one of the more
underrated novels no this is still not
like doing anything i think i'm number
four right you're number four okay are
you number four cause yeah what number
am i whatever i am at
and you go towards your ultimate end
i wanted to be bowser oh i'm bowser i i
could be married i'll trade you if you
don't know well i'm not anybody right
now i'm peach
yeah we go that's the way we think
that's pretty funny if you're peach it
is a little bit what is a woman what is
it
italian what else do i pick up i think
we're all good
the promise by kai and potak signed i
picked up a leon yours exodus sign wow i
picked up uh today actually i picked up
animal farm signed by orwell oh yeah
shockingly these are not wildly
expensive because they have words
exactly
[Music]
uh how do i go which controller do i use
that not that one clearly
okay
blue button
um so i have yet to move i don't know
which uh
oh i see okay i don't know which
oh there
yeah well this isn't going fantastically
well for me
you're going backwards
oh no that's not you oh that's not that
guy someone's going who's going against
the wall right peach just beat me
talk like that congress person
oh i'm number four
yeah you know i just beat me did you
take my thing how do i make my uh the
weapons fire yeah where are the hooks to
kill
yeah that was the outside of the other
driving the other day oh my god ah shoot
i keep hitting are you winning i mean
just like this company through the
incompetence of others
[Laughter]
so what are the stakes here i mean if i
win no well then i tell you what a woman
is
i remember the graphics being better on
this well you were a child so i guess
yeah it's like everyone was really
really tall when you were a kid
so if i win you all have to wear sweet
baby getting t-shirts on your show never
happens
i won't even mention sweet baby
i still have no idea what it is it's
people who like you yes what do you mean
who are these and why why does it how'd
it get called the
[Music]
[Music]
making this very dark
sweet baby gang is the most positive
thing i've ever done in my life
so that's easy oh my god since you're an
asperger
yeah that's actually easy to imagine
[Music]
i just won somehow like i wasn't even
trying
this i hit you with something
devastating i finished third that's
unfortunate you guys really were you
guys since you're fired oh yeah
except for number who was number four
what's up i think i'm number one
yeah because i didn't know which one i
was trying to play one through though
all right
so we're going to swap out mr clayton
oh yeah yeah all right how's it going
man what's going on man thanks for
letting me destroy you guys on mario
kart yeah yeah yeah absolutely so i i
would play one version of this called
don't drink and drive where you have to
finish your drink before you finish the
game
i think
that would make this a little bit more
entertaining well bowser is basically
the worst character i would not know any
of this but do the characters determine
how fast like there's uh weight so uh
bowser is takes like less damage
basically
yoshi's pretty much the best
where's luigi i got hit how do i fire
the weapons z oh z yeah with z the
trigger yeah the trigger on your finger
oh that was unfortunate it was good
there we go smacked by some sort of
shallow of some kind yeah now i'm losing
knowledge which is never yeah this game
[Music]
here's the trick if you've got a shell
hold z and it creates a shield for you
in the back
[Music]
oh i keep hitting these bombs yeah it's
like playing kid
tim is like playing video games with
plato
he knows all the secrets of the universe
oh yeah there's another trick called a
mini turbo
you jump slide tap the trigger twice to
the left and you'll super speed i'm not
gonna remember any of that the only uh
game i ever really played was grand
theft auto i used to play like old
school doom
on the computer
like people would devolve into body
parts when you shot them
i feel that was an inspiration for my
life yeah back of mine doesn't start
when i when i try to start driving it
like just spins around it's like the
ratings on your show yeah it just keeps
smoothing if you try and accelerate too
soon before the lights are going off in
the beginning
you'll spin out of control you got to
wait for it right before the last light
goes up yes i wish i knew that before
these four races that we're doing so
it's kind of fun i don't know if this is
really good content or not but i mean
i've played this game in 20 years it's
pretty fun i'm going to be the next
pewdiepie i'm going to make my millions
on this game that'd be the first time
you've been productive
if we could somehow monetize you yeah as
a video game player
i hate that deal hey hip guys
hey hit a hey watch that make a
deontological reference about mario kart
that's a winner i mean honestly it's not
that hard to draw michael all you really
have to do is what matt and i do you
just say that a man is not a woman you
just go to kids just keep saying it
overnight
i i assumed the libs would stop throwing
a fit over that it occurred the only two
major protests i've had at my events one
of which
resulted in a looney tune shooting with
a super soaker were were on that top
yeah they can't resist they can't resist
it nothing bad i'm just actually trying
to win as hard as i can
and i have nothing funny to say at all
not to do the rest of us
good point we can cut this together and
do something with it i'm just going to
sit over here in this sand for no reason
and
yeah this is going oh yeah
how do i even like get out of this place
i don't know i just did what shut up
mathis
who's playing who here mathis i don't
need that kind of [ __ ] from you
oh i just got hit right before the
finish line that's not fair i did i won
the first round right you can't take
that away from me okay i finished third
third and fourth so
wow clearly i didn't spend enough time
doing useless when i was a teenager
let's change course real quick
[Music]
what does the d button do and how's it
different from oh man bowser is so trash
as i'm trying to cheat right now that's
kind of the whole point
but bowser is basically possible to
cheat with oh lightning
wow
since you know clearly what you're doing
i hope that's not how god wins the
universe
who's responsible for that lightning and
he's like i think it was me
i figured you had more plan than that
god
yeah we're just gonna keep playing
oh i did it yeah basically if you had
any plans for us the rest of the
afternoon
yeah this actually is fun
why didn't i do this as a kid i did it
all day
that makes me feel really bad about
myself because i like to spend time
reading lots of books going to high
school
like
going to law school
investing so much time on philosophy
and seems like yeah i spend the whole
time in a mario kart that makes the same
amount of money
what a great country
i send out tim has turned me into a
communist i have no idea how i managed
to succeed wasting so much time doing
things like this
oh hey look i'm in the first place now
how'd you get before i was just in first
yeah you know
yeah yeah i guess so uh justin in second
but no longer
when you know the secrets of mario kart
you're unstoppable
yeah i jumped over the wall i'm just
feeling bad i'm just running directly
into walls again like the president
man if i had to sum up this game in one
word it would be
excuse me i was climbing the foothold
he knows all the best words that was the
last person
we're just gonna hit buttons randomly
and see if things happen
i also like our presidents
see i'm so far ahead of you i'm gonna
get to the finish line just wait
how do you know where i am
no
so there's a map in the middle that
shows where you guys are oh yeah but now
i'm looking at dad i'm running into
walls
i appreciate that distraction that was
good oh no oh no we'll hit me with
lightning
oh why god
i thought lightning could not strike
twice i was clearly mistaken wait did
someone just pass me but i'm still in
first place oh shoot i hit that bomb
i'm only hitting the final lap now
i don't know
wow i'm still in the first lap i think
oh and i'm hitting him by turtle shells
what kind of crazy world is this you're
just going along minding your own
business suddenly by lighting an
internal shelter you know that's the way
to go that's just
you know as augustine said
i i'm i'm actually just waiting at the
finish line for you guys are you kidding
me yeah but i think it'll take something
that's so cute yeah you are you are
gonna
it's gonna take a while
haunting penalty i'm a communist and i
think it's only fair that i wait to give
you a fair chance all right and then
and then take us to advancement
oh yeah when you try to assert my
right i have to say power just pleased
with glorio
i was promised war and eo and i was
delivered neither
all right who's the go who's green is
that i don't know i don't know can we
play chris after this
tetris is my game that's my gm
that's a pretty big donkey kong country
guy oh man luigi's coming up yeah man
he's going for the win yeah get it get
it get it
all right he's kind of close totally
good there i am i'm getting it
almost that booster i saw you trying to
pull that trick
sad well to be fair i cheated but at
least i didn't finish it
you know how did you get so far ahead so
right at the beginning of course
princess can you jump over you know it's
not fair to have the women racing my
producer actually thinking about that i
cheated i choose to win but all that
matters it says one next to mine i'll
play one more time that is all that
matters
like thanks for having me
yeah wow
that was the most fun thing we've done
ever at daily life
you guys want to play smash brothers
next